Herr Bruder auf Europa kommen wir gleich
noch mal ganz in Ruhe zu sprechen aber
sie haben eigentlich die perfekte
Überleitung zu ihrem eigenen Thema
gegeben schneckenland Deutschland ja
Deutschland ist
schneckenland wäre schon ein riesiges
Kompliment nein Stillstand Land
Stillstand mein Lieblingsbeispiel der
letzten Wochen war die Ankündigung dass
es Deutschland in Deutschland eine
deutschland-takt geben wird für die
Bundesbank es wird daran gearbeitet dass
sie sagen wir von Kiel nach
Berchtesgaden ohne Umsteigen fahren
können vielleicht auch mit Verspätungen
und von Aachen nach Chemnitz genauso und
wenn sie in Goslar umsteigen können sich
überlegen wohin sie fahren wollen und
dieser Deutschlandtag sollte 20 30 in
Kraft treten dann gab es eine Verlegung
die nicht weit kommuniziert wurde auf 20
50 und jetzt hat die Bundesbahn unter
Verkehrsminister erklärt wenn alles
klappt wird das 20 70 werden wir haben
heute 20 23 jetzt stellen Sie sich bitte
folgen vor nehmen wir an es wird 2050
und nicht 2017
2050 werde ich wahrscheinlich tot sein
was ich ein unerhörten Skandal finde
mich wie kann sich die Welt ohne mich
weiterdrehen aber die 27 Jahre bleiben
wir noch und jetzt denken wir einen
anderen Moment zurück von heute 27 Jahre
zurück in das Jahr 1996 vom Merkel vor
9/11 vor Fukushima vor der Finanzkrise
2008 und vor der Flucht und Welle und
anderen Problemen alle diese Ereignisse
sind von niemand vorausgesehen worden
und schon gar nicht von den Experten die
uns heute sagen dass im nächsten
verteidigenflation zurückgehen wird den
ganzen Experten haben versagt und jetzt
wagen die gleichen Leute Vorhersagen
über 30 bis 50 Jahre das ist unerhört
das ist Märchen erzählerei wirklich aber
hat sich das zu früher geändert ich
meine früher gab es auch große
Herausforderung noch vor 30 40 Jahren
und die expertenlagen die damals immer
richtig
sagen noch nie richtig und die großen
vorausforderungen über sein schönes
Synonym für Probleme an meint eigentlich
Probleme und sagt challenges stimmt
Politiker Sprache große Herausforderung
stellen würden kurz vor dem Absprung ja
die großen Herausforderungen waren die
Lohnnebenkosten der grüne Punkt das
Dosenpfand das waren unsere Probleme vor
20 30 Jahren und das hat sich natürlich
im Zuge der europäischen Integration
also der Gleichschaltung der
europäischen Länder wahnsinnig verstärkt
und es ist nun mal so wenn Sie ein
Geleitzug haben wenn sie zehn Boote
haben und die wollen alle im selben
Tempo fahren dann gibt das schwächste
Boot das Temperatur genau das überlegen
wir jetzt und die können einfach nicht
zugeben die Leute in dieser Politik sind
die können nicht zugeben dass ich geehrt
haben das stimmt die können es gibt
keinen Weg zurück das können Sie nicht
wissen sie Deutschland hat ihn nicht
zugeben wirklich eine Pole Position
weltweit an sich hätten die Deutschen
oder die Nazis nach Stalingrad sagen
können genug wir gehen nein sie mussten
noch zwei Jahre weiter kämpfen da würde
ich gerne einmal Frau Hermenau einbinden
wie können die Politik kann nicht
zugeben dass es falsch war hat der
Bruder gesagt sie waren ganz lange im
Bundestag ist das so könnte
erstens eine ganze Landesliste die
hinter ihnen darauf lauert dass man sie
irgendwie nicht wieder aufstellt nicht
wieder wählt und so weiter und deswegen
wenn sie was zugeben dann sind sie dann
schlecht gewesen und dann hat am andere
Gründe ihren Platz einzunehmen der sehr
hoch bezahlt wird viele erreichen das im
Berufsleben nicht das Gehalt oder die
Diät die ein Bundestagsabgeordneter
bekommt das ist das eigentlich liegt
aktuell glaube ich bei 12000
€. die da kann man die teurerung und das
zweite ist aus meiner Sicht ähm
das ist auch menschlich kriegen dass die
Leute nicht hin wir haben das nachher
friedlichen Revolution gemerkt die
Partei Die Linke und die PDS die ganzen
Heutungen die Stadt gefunden haben die
Kommunisten konnten einfach nicht
zugeben dass sie sich geirrt hatten und
wir waren die ganzen kleinen Mäuschen
und retten in ihrem ganzen versucht
haben sie nicht hin schlecht also muss
der Sozialismus irgendwie weiter
verteidigt werden und dasselbe passiert
jetzt bei den Grünen meiner Meinung nach
und die SPD muss entscheiden ob sie
damit geht oder nicht mitgeht sie würden
die DDR mit den Grünen gleichsetzen
nicht gleichsetzen aber es gibt
vergleichbare Mechanismen ich habe dich
ja wüst es ist nicht identisch das kann
gar nicht sein außerdem gibt es heute
Internet die Methoden sind deutlich
subtiler aber unabhängig davon ist es
natürlich eine menschliche Grundhaltung
wenn man jetzt 20 Jahre lang dafür
gekämpft hat dass die Energiewende kommt
und man hat sich genau ausgedacht wie
sein soll und nun ist die ganze
Versuchsanordnung zusammengebrochen ja
aber trotzdem richtig überlegt so das
geht aber nicht weil die die Idee war
aber gut wir haben 84 Millionen Menschen
in diesem Land die davon abhängen wie es
läuft ich kann den Bürgern immer nur
empfehlen das mache ich inzwischen auch
deutlich glauben Sie nicht mehr ein
Riester Verträge an Versicherung lassen
Sie das alles die Banken können alles
konfisieren der Stadt kann alles
konfiszieren sie müssen sich völlig neue
Überlegungen anstrengen wie sie ihr
Alter absichern wie Sie Ihre Familie
absichern wir müssen völlig neue Wege
gehen weil auch diese Systeme alle nicht
mehr sauber arbeiten das ist alles
verlängert mit künstlichem Geld das noch
keiner verdient hat wir werden da ganz
neue Wege gehen müssen mit meinem Umfeld
und ich wir haben uns völlig neu
entschieden wir beraten auch Leute weil
so geht es einfach nicht mehr Herr
Bruder wie ist es denn bei Ihnen wenn
Sie darauf schauen können Sie schon Züge
des Sozialismus bei den Grünen entdecken
Züge ich entdecke ab und zu Züge der
Vernunft bei den Grünen aber man kann ja
für den Zügen des Sozialismus reden die
sind auf dem Trip zu einer
Staatswirtschaft ja seinem staatlichen
Macht Monopol zu einer Planwirtschaft
und sie fangen natürlich klein an Sie
werden nicht sofort Leute enteignen aber
es gibt eine Kampagne nach der anderen
die wir leben sollen ohne Fett ohne
Zucker jetzt ohne Auto ohne Alkohol
sowieso aus den Ausnahme Situationen
gucken sich nur die Verordnungen an und
gucken sich die Namen dieser
Verordnungen an das Gute kindergesetz
wir haben einen Enkel das sind 30 Kinder
in der Kita und die haben nur zwei
Betreuer davon ist einer immer krank
so sieht die Wirklichkeit aus und das
Tollste ist leider haben sie rechtlich
für den gerne widersprechen zum einen
sagen die meisten dass sie in der Tat
nicht bereit sind Fehler einzugestehen
aber die Geschichte geht noch weiter die
hat noch eine zweite Ebene der in
Familie Leute die den Sozialismus
wiederherstellen wollen sagen dass da in
der DDR oder in Polen das war kein
Sozialismus wir machen jetzt den wahren
Sozialisten ja wissen Sie jede Idee hat
was Gutes nicht auch ich muss zugeben
auch bei der Nazis gab es zwar gute Idee
nicht Kraft durch Freude das hat vielen
Leuten Spaß gemacht aber das hat das
System nicht gerettet das System ist
verkommen wie das russische System heute
und das einzusehen wie kam es dass die
SPD sich dermaßen in Putin verlieben
konnte dass sie vom Platz weg bis
Schröder alle mit dem Pudding
fratamisiert haben meine das war doch
abzusehen was da passiert er hat über
100 russische Matrosen absaufen lassen
damals dass die Kurs Frank weil er nicht
internationale Hilfe annehmen wollte
deswegen musst du 100 Leute diesen
beschissenen U-Boot sterben ja aber dann
waren ganz alle überrascht und da ist
uns ja als Lupen reine Demokrat verkauft
worden wir haben eine Reparaturbetrieb
hier von der Digitalisierung bis zu den
Schulen wenn 25% der Hauptschüler nach
der vierten oder fünften Klasse nicht
lesen und die schreiben können dann ist
grünlich was schief gelaufen
den Menschen verändern
Politiker wollen immer die Menschen ein
bisschen verändern also das ist alles
für sich ihr gutes Recht und ja das ist
dann ein WLAN danach zu entscheiden ob
sie dann dieses Programm unterstützen
wollen
ich es ist natürlich tatsächlich schwer
für Politiker zuzugeben dass die Fehler
gemacht haben und manchmal leider sogar
noch als sie nicht mehr im Amt sind also
solange sie im Amt sind da kann man das
auch verstehen ne man muss viele gewählt
werden und so weiter aber wenn man z.B
auf Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel schaut
wie findet immer noch dass wir es
geschafft haben die findet immer noch
als sie danach gefragt wurde das die
Energiepolitik und die Russland Politik
richtig war das finde ich dann nachher
problematisch aus ähm eine grüne Partei
die jetzt auch in der Ampel Koalition
noch nicht so ganz lange im Amt ist wir
haben ganz ganz lange
Regierungen unter Merkel von SPD und CDU
ähm gehabt die unter anderem in der
Migrationspolitik und in der
Flüchtlingspolitik überhaupt nichts
gemacht haben die hatten die Zeit lange
Zeit unter etwas zu ändern haben es
nicht gemacht wir haben in dem Bereich
mindestens eine Regierung die ist
zumindest in ihrem Programm geschrieben
hat sie haben zwar noch nichts gemacht
richtig konkret aber zumindest die
Vorsätze stimmen und ich hoffe dass sie
unter Druck der Ereignisse auch dazu
kommen diese umzusetzen sie haben sehr
Politiker wollen generell Menschen
erziehen was verspricht sich die Politik
davon
ja das ist nicht nur die Politik
Menschen Wähler wollen auch andere
Menschen und andere Wähler erzielen also
dass nein das ist ein innerent an der
Politik in der Politik werden
Vorstellung über wie wir die
Gesellschaft gestalten wollen wie wir
zusammen leben wollen umgesetzt in
Wahlprogramme und Parteien bewerben sich
dann bei dem also es ist jetzt nicht das
ist nicht
einzigartig für die Grünen das wollen
auch wenn die CDU hat auch bestimmte
Vorstellungen die AFD jetzt vor
sicherlich sicherlich bestimmte
Vorstellungen die Linken haben bestimmte
Vorstellung und es gibt den Wettbewerb
letztendlich um zu entscheiden welche
Vorstellung sich durchsetzen also man
kann jetzt alles alles auf die Politiker
abzuschieben ist manchmal
unterschiedlich es ist ein wir haben
Wahlen äh die Regierung jetzt sind die
ist auch gewählt worden also das ist
auch in demokratische Prozess also
Thema schimpfen will muss man auch auf
die Wähler die die Parteien wählen wenn
die Katze sagt werden auch Wahlen
widerrufen und wiederholt wenn Sie ein
Wahlergebnis für uns zumutbar hält das
glaube ich in Thüringen passiert oder
welches bedeutende Landfahrer ist
aber es gibt noch etwas was ich bitte
sehr berücksichtigen wir haben in
Deutschland einmaliges Programm das gibt
es in keiner Demokratie das
Innenministerium hat ein Programm
aufgelegt das Hunderte von Millionen
Euro kostet und dass Demokratie leben
heißt in jedem normalen demokratischen
Land wird die Regierung von Volk erzogen
bei uns hat die Regierung ein Programm
zu Erziehung des Volkes aufgelegt das
ist einmalig das ist eine unglaubliche
übrig ist und sie geraten in keine
europäischen Land so schnell in den
Verdacht ein Recht ein Rechtsradikaler
zu sein fehlt mir doch ein Vogel ja das
stimmt auch doch doch nein
genauso gut passieren
einen in Schweden noch viel leichter
passieren aber ich liebe euch bis vor
kurzem ich lebe nun mal hier um die
Schweden haben die Politik revidiert den
haben gerade die Politik auch revidiert
gegangen sie haben in Holland auch
einige Notbremsen gezogen nachdem sie
gemerkt haben dass sie mit ihrer
Zuwanderungspolitik nicht gerade die
Probleme ihres Landes gemindert haben
nicht wahr ja das stimmt aber auch
Deutschland hat schon ein paar
Gesetzesänderung durchgeführt in der
Vergangenheit
das ist auch nicht so was ich kenne mich
da ziemlich gut aus
Integrationspolitik in verschiedenen
europäischen Ländern da steht
Deutschland wirklich nicht als
schlimmste Junge der Klasse da also
lange will ich gar nicht es gibt
wirklich andere Länder wie Frankreich
oder auch Schweden die da viele viele
schön dass sie aus Niederlande gekommen
sind in Deutschland zu verteidigen
voll in einer kurzen Unterbrechung sind
wir wieder da wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie